[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
maïté j'ai l'impression que vous avez
été vous promener au bord de la main
c'était la pêche vous vous avez rapporté
des merveilles c'est tellement frais
sont totalement dingue on s'est vraiment
appétissant qu'est-ce que vous avez
l'intention de nous faire
alala ce que j'ai toujours eu l'habitude
de faire un gaspacho aux ultras ça ça va
être assez bon et certainement il ya une
seconde recette sûrement oui et après
décret pour fruits de mer sur l'île
dusautoir les deux prétendants mais ça
j'en ai jamais fait cela vous et bien
oui
alors osez malgré leur traditionnel pas
les huîtres le gaspacho c'est un plat
traditionnel d'andalousie
voilà alors j'irai là bas pour goûter le
vrai si vous le faites mieux que moi
mais avec les gîtes reviendra un peu
breton arrêtera mélange améliore voilà
qu'est ce qu'il vous faut considérer
c'est pas mal de choses dit nous faut du
père il nous faut un concombre il faut
de l'huile et du vinaigre de l'huile
d'olive bien entendu il nous faut de la
ciboulette des tomates de l'ail de
l'estragon bien entendu des huîtres des
moules à lors des caucus les rênes à
ryadh sociale 70 ans et ses superbes
sont magnifiques le corps il devrait
ensuite il ya des noms mais sans y
revenir après alors des côtes
oui les petits coquillages et bien sûr
de l'armagnac
et puisqu'on fait des crêpes pour faire
lé clair il faut des oeufs de la farine
du lait du beurre et pas de sucre du sel
du poivre
voilà une piste raide des coquillages
voilà par quoi avez vous l'intention de
commencer par le carpaccio n'osais pas
du carpaccio gars car voiture ces
détresses et italiennes gaspachos et
voilà et c'est andalou très bien qu'à 68
vous avez préparé des légumes la joie
que vous avez plaidé thomas pas osé
couper en morceaux les concombres les
eaux des gorges et épépinez aussi les
rejoindre qu'est ce que vous faites en
premier alors voilà du père de l'ami de
fer que je vais faire tremper dans l'eau
pour la ramollir
oui et pendant que sa trempe vous allez
me demander la maurine voilà et on va
attaquer alors passer ses petits légumes
à la moulinette là alors on va mettre un
petit peu on va partager avec les
concombres
vous y allez là je voulais c'est tournez
vous ajouterez les petits autre truc
après pas
vous donnerez si vous voulez remettre
après ça resterait ça passerait pas oui
comme ch et fédéral ça n'a aucune
importance
on va le perdre comme ça voilà et là il
vous l'avouer après vous allez pas
traduire d'après donc on a moins honnête
je les achète très très faibles pour
remettre comme ça voilà vous en voulez
encore un peu ça va un petit peu plus
pour la soupe du côté d'une soupe
finalement et alors là pour les uns plus
moderne n'est ce pas si on veut on peut
le passer au mix haras de tarbes de
campagne relativement facile voilà c'est
plus facile parce que ce sera il y aura
pas assez - mais nous nous sommes encore
de l'ancien temps eh ben on appris à
faire la cuisine avec nos grands mères
n'avaient pas de x alors on a gardé des
vielles habitudes sur certaines jours
c'est pas mal déjà voilà pris une jolie
couleur et cet appétissant là alors on
rsr opération c'était donc la tomate et
le comté le comprends c'est joli ensuite
que vous allez arriver là je vais
rajouter toutes les herbes
alors là il nous fait très très faim ou
non c'est bien vous avez de l'estragon
de l'estragon comme ça ça me paraît très
bien voilà et votre pain il est assez
mou il a passé là dedans ou pas vous
croyez avoir et réduire et la bière a
molli oh oui on les bouge un peu
enfin ça y est on rajoute un petit peu
de pain ça on m'a dit que c'était
facultative on peut faire comme on veut
salir encore là c'est très bien gâche
pas et dont je crois l'avoir et ensuite
il va falloir assaisonner quand même un
petit peu tout ça rien sur en plus des
herbes
bien sûr ça n'aurait pas de loup voilà
on est dedans je vous enlever ça vous
n'aurez plus besoin alors sel et poivre
pareil sel et poivre
un soupçon de vinaigre mais très peu
très peu toutefois vu c'est pourquoi
en quoi la peine à peine voilà rihanna
ces aides les olives et de l'huile
ça va être très très beaux arts ça mais
je crois qu'il faut le mettre vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup je gagne ou longtemps
pour qu'elle soit glace et là je pars ce
canard s'est jamais jamais fait je crois
que ça va ça me paraît bien ça me paraît
bien à la maison puisque c'est un
gaspacho aux 8 qui va falloir s'occuper
des illustres on va le faire pocher
elles sont bien bel maille séparés de
huit fruits dont quoi allez-vous les
possédants euros levis gré oui voilà
alors j'aimerais vous avez récolté s'est
mis à chauffer depuis ça et puis ça y
est et on en a juste quelques unes c'est
vite faire une deux minutes y'a quoi ah
oui c'est toujours très facile là comme
ça je les aime la vente
enfin on s'amuse le plus petit de
l'homme et bien le temps quelle poche
est-ce que vous avez un petit quelque
chose à raconter dans bien sûr dans ce
que vous dites
gaspacho ah oui bon je fais des progrès
là je suis très fier on va vous sinon
mais on voit que je suis habitué à
manger bavoil alors là on va rajouter
des petits cubes pour que cette contre
la dengue est juste un petit peu près
tout se réduit un petit peu de tomates
des tomates pareil
voilà hélas oui et puis nous appelons à
la mobilisation pocher on va les déposer
par ici au retour c'est moche ailleurs
plus haut non non non non non je vous
conseille pas d'essayer
alors ça regarde joli nom et tout ça
c'est bon frigidaire pendant longtemps
il faut que ce soit préféré conserver
et pendant ce temps nous allons préparer
nos craintes la patte sur toi crêpes
vous avez mis dedans ce que est ce que
tout bon c'est quoi c'est à dire dans la
pâte à crêpes l'algérie 3e je bats les
oeufs les et saler poivrer
j'ai fait fondre offre un petit peu de
beurre de nouvelles voilà un petit peu
de beurre 50 g de beurre à peu près
défendu par ap à brûler je l'aimé de da
à payer vie de la farine tuk tuk tuk tuk
tuk tuk tuk c'est un petit peu de lait
jusqu'à l'hallali paix de l'affichage de
qu'on veut être joli elle a maintenant
elles reposent un peu et qu'est ce que
vous faites est alors ici le dors je
vais mettre mes coquilles saint-jacques
à ce quoi vous les avez un peu et mince
avantage d'être très très belle et noah
était très très dense eux les allemands
c'est ça qu'on va mettre les petits
morceaux
il ya donc eu une démarche déjà atteint
des machines à votre tour là bas les
exigences et les poires bien sûr
toujours voilà
et pendant que sa cuisse eh bien vous
avez la cocotte que vous avez préparé
que vous avez chauffer j'imagine déjà
que c'est voilà pour ces moules les a
nettoyés bien rendre actes et voilà bien
propre la plus les coques tous à la fois
vous annoncez un tout petit peu pour des
petits coups oui avec un petit peu de
vin blanc ne s'agit pas bien entendu
tout le monde fait tout le monde sait ça
parce qu'elles vont lâcher de l'eau
salée en s'ouvrant et on va se servir de
ce jus bien bon vous allez voir la tombe
amoureux et on les guette on les observe
et on attend n'attendent que ne
s'ouvrent les moules et les coques sont
des coquilles et ont l'âge espagne
garder leur jus de cuisson qu'on n'a
filtré on a beaucoup travaillé on a
laissé la reyssouze vous faites
maintenant alors là quand j'ai fait des
crêpes aussi a eu de cris cuisse alors
j'ai mis une casserole oui je vais faire
comme une petite baie shabelle oui il ya
des raisons d'un orphelin je vais forme
en voiture devant lui avec un couteau ça
ira mieux
voilà alors miley ne fait pas brûler le
beurre il faut que ce soit ma ronde avec
des sans abri ne passerait pas ce genre
de la farine de la farine et quand
j'aurai mon père lui parce qu'il est bon
là de ma personne était chaude
voilà alors je vais mettre une cuillère
de farid parce qu'on va pas faire
beaucoup rinne a une grosse hausse voilà
alors qu'est ce que vous allez mouillé
ça je vais mouiller avec votre jus et le
jus des coquilles saint-jacques que j'ai
ici à côté vous commencez par l'école à
10 h salle est donc tournée l'examen
attention roulement au nom un tout petit
peu au-delà du jus des moules un désir
désir vous faire ses preuves avant que
c'est un petit peu là d un peu plus
voilà c'est bon et puis voilà et parce
que ça y est et ça y est et ensuite la
traite pas les pentes le programme
attend gentiment voilà la sauce et jolie
retourner la crêpe détourné à sion s'est
ensuite plus qu'à préparer le plat
exactement
et comment allez-vous les garnir alors
sécrète pour finir et la source vous
avez mis quoi dedans
dans ma petite source ce que j'ai fait
et qui est succulente j'aimais les
coquillages oui voilà
alors ça les coquilles saint jacques
voilà ça donnait ça je vais m voilà vous
regardez où la france est au dessus de
tout soupçon
on plie au niveau des rails et 21 et hop
voilà prêt très bien vous voir par lui à
travers cette jolie saint jacques
rien n'est plus la danse et bien normes
falloir un peu de choses tout autour et
moi et on finit de mettre la société en
regard des mois sa sauce et ça ça va
être très très très très très bon on va
y avoir droit à bichat et oui
non je vous assure c'est lisse et puis
ces délicieuses et d'ajouter avec ses
crêpes aux saint-jacques et aux
coquillages
il faut un bon verre de vin blanc oui
sec
ah oui selon m ça va de soi et bien
alors à vendre mon registre est
délicieux bien notre gaspacho qui nous
attend gaspacho ça fait bon alors vous
nous avez mis à tous parce que les gens
l'aiment plus ou moins assaisonner plus
ou moins fort qu'est ce que vous nous
avez mis dans les petites coupelles là
on alain de petits légumes l'emmena la
ciboulette la tomate l'ail les gens du
coin vous rend très très très fort voilà
et le concombre et le résultat avec les
foires au dessus est formidable et dans
son assiette on ajoute selon ce qu'on
aime un peu de l'ain un peu comme on
veut au choix
nous avons là deux places que vraiment
pas difficile à faire ça m'a aidé c'est
vrai que c'est vrai que c'est parce
qu'il allait créer c'est rien à faire il
reste facile vous à l'épaté tous vos
amis avec des crêpes aux copies argent
alors n'hésitez par à au revoir bientôt
bon appétit à bientôt
[Musique]